the pit represents the earth and then
all the red stuff around it is the
neighboring galaxies in the stem
represents the trajectory oh hi weirdoes
here at the score party where we're
learning some fascinating evolutionary
science which as you can see is a pretty
good for impressing girls
or is this a really interesting
perspective on all of life that you're
trying to advance life at every stage
you start kind of microbial in the cell
stage eventually you get large we were
on land in the evolution creature stage
then we'll shoot evolved intelligence he
went to the tribal stage and you start
developing kind of the personality of
your tribe and then eventually admitted
in the Civil stage where technology
starts getting higher disturb link
cities vehicles ships airplanes and then
the last phase of space where for the
first time you leave your home planet
and then you can actually go out through
this huge galaxy where every world is
unique and it's populated with stuff
that other players have created while
they were planning in we knew that our
players given the right tools would put
out tremendous amounts of creativity and
we've seen that with the Sims before
using kind of much lower power tools and
so well the first things we do is for
spend a lot of time working on these
tool sets so in 20 clicks player can
basically replicate what a Pixar artist
might spend weeks making now once we had
those we also made sure the content was
very compressible so in a player makes
something compresses down to about 20 k
even though when it's in memory on your
computer it's about three megs running
around the world so that means we could
send this step up to the net to a
database very easily very low friction
and then populate everybody else's world
was this creative output so basically
we're outsourcing must the creativity of
filling out these millions of unique
worlds to the players you just never
know what's going to pop in your world
you know sometimes it's Care Bears and
Klingons and other times it's real earth
animals we had people draw pictures of
creatures before we ever made the editor
just look at the drawings that they made
what sort of things do they pull these
creatures had to think about them this
is the creature I made which is in fact
a creature which reflects my own
conclusions about what might be very
common variations on
other planets I call it super sapiens
because what it is is a homo sapiens we
are our species Homo sapiens but one
that's actually improved a lot of things
about us which aren't perfect we only
have two arms you better to have for an
eye in the back of the head would be
helpful and we just wonder why evolution
did not produce that we found that most
people right off of that one something
bilaterally symmetrical and there seemed
to be very good reasons if you're moving
on land it have something bilaterally
symmetrical on the parts you know we
wanted to have a lot of diversity for
the type of life cycles these creatures
might I'll live some of them might be
small and stealthy other one is large
and powerful other ones very social so
the parts that you use on your creature
kind of reflect these different
strategies but actually what you do in
the game you know if I go on a tack
things arm friendly will impact my
attributes so we look at two different
things here we look at how you build
your future the parts that you use but
then we look at how you behave in the
world and your behavior and every level
is actually setting what eventually
becomes your cultural personality you
might be an herbivore that's a predator
that's industrious or whatever depending
how you putting the first of your phases
so even up you know to civ tribe
whatever you're gonna have superpowers
based upon the fact that you're let's
say an herbivore so these early early
decisions actually still have
consequence all the way through the game
we wanted players to have an interesting
kind of back story to the creature like
the Vulcans and Star Trek or this very
logical peaceful race but they started
out as this very warlike aggressive race
and we wanted players to have that kind
of schizophrenic backstory with their
races in the game whenever you make
something in the editor of compressed
genome that thing goes up to our server
and enters our database we call support
pedia you can browse this database
actually at support calm without even
buying again and when the other people
playing the game it uses this database
to populate their world the computer is
now controlling the creatures that
they've made but I can click on a
creature and find out who made it I can
send them a message on the creature the
creature actually kind of becomes a
little trading card in the game and I
can use that creature in a number of
different ways I can also go out to the
top of the game
and grab collections of pictures to
build a sport cast and I can subscribe
to a sport cast which brings that theme
into my game I can also put my friends
on my buddy list and anything my friends
make while they're playing spore will
appear somewhere in my world and I'll
discover them as I'm playing sport so we
have a lot of asynchronous interaction
between the players going on and on the
website will have reports back from
these other worlds as to how your
creatures fairing and other people's
galaxies but no two planets are the same
everyone is your meat already populated
with unique stuff no way we can do this
is by having Williams of tires basically
are creatively building this world
collectively as they play I think what
we're trying to do here at a high level
is we're trying to find a way to harvest
the collective creativity of millions of
people and then distill it down and
concentrated and I think that's you know
we found that computers are okay like
artificial intelligence but what they're
really good at is they're good at
harvesting human intelligence if you
look at something like Google really you
know what gives the intelligence to
Google search results are all the other
people putting links in to web pages in
Google just harvesting that intelligence
so we found the computers are very good
at harvesting human intelligence and
redistributing it much more so than
recreating intelligence with spore we're
doing the same thing with creativity
we're trying to find a way to harvest
the creativity of all these players
distill down and then redistribute it to
make the game more interesting to
everybody else
you